time now for a very special CBS
morning's deals what you might call the
Vlad to Dad Edition we've got some items
that will help all parents and in
particular Vlad as it gets ready to be a
dad all at exclusive discounts to start
shopping right now scan the QR code you
see on your screen or visit cbsdeals.com
we've got lifestyle host Gail bass here
to help us with everything we got a
jacket here that is compatible with a
car seat talk to me about it yes baby
shower boarding for Vlad You're
Expecting baby girl so I brought baby
Gail to demonstrate this this is the
Buckle me baby coat and what's really
good about this is that you can get the
baby in the car without the struggle of
taking the jacket off putting them in
the car seat then putting the jacket
back on because they're not supposed to
sit in the car seat with their jacket on
underneath the strap so this thing just
opens right up just like that just like
that and and it has a side it has a side
velcro and a side zipper I was just
playing with it and I got I didn't
receive all these at home to just test
them out and this was the hardest one
because I'm like this looks really cool
but how does it work when you don't
actually have a baby yet so well I get
it I mean the thing that's great about
this is you just use this zipper use it
like a pullover their head will fit
through it right and like it is a hassle
taking the jacket off before you put the
baby in the car seat with what you're
supposed to do and then putting that
jacket back on when it's cold when you
get to where you're going I mean how do
you spell hassle it is a big time delay
and what if your regular three kids
going to school in the morning this is
great so this this changes that yeah and
what's also great is we have this for 29
off so it's a great deal and it comes in
multiple colors yeah and it's a safety
feature also for safety for you this was
the one that I was really interested in
this is one of our big sellers because
the Clean Air XL and the Clean Air Pro
are great for that baby room because
number one they filter out odors and
they filter out germs pathogens bacteria
all that stuff that you don't want in
the baby's room because you know you
want them to be happy healthy not worry
about it but I love that it also filters
odor so I say you know
apparently the diaper pail is a fake yes
yes and you'll want that and what's
really nice is it's quiet and it can
also go in the office because when they
eventually get out of diapers you could
take it to the office I like this one in
my car I keep that in there this one has
a cup holder and it could be up to four
hours in length it also in filtering air
it filters out a pet dander yes pet
dander is going to be he's already
exploring the crib my cat and I don't
want that dander that the cat might want
to try to jump into this we'll get to
that in a minute but right now what are
you offering this one is 160 off you can
get up to 62 percent off on these Clean
Air Products but these are popular so
you want to get on now okay get 180 off
and it's down to 79.99 to 99 that is a
deal pretty good pretty good fantastic
deal all right build a bag right I love
these because they are so sturdy the
baby might try to crawl in it the cat
might just run it but look how much
stuff this one is and it's hot and it's
durable this is made with Eva okay
that's ethylene vinyl acetate so it's
going to resist cracking it's going to
be protected from the UV lights when you
take the baby to the beach when you take
the baby's toys to Grandma this is
another thing you can use to carry
everything around or groceries it
doesn't have to be for just the baby
because I you know my nieces and nephews
are all grown up so I use it for
groceries you put the baby in here uh I
would
heading out right what what I'm not
recommended
why do they call it a build a bag
because you can build it yourself you
could pick the handles yourself you
could put the uh you could put this
little tchotchke on here so if you could
design it the way you want to and it
comes in multiple colors so you can
interchange the parts out the way you
want it and design it the way you want
it you could be a bad designer another
use I could see for this is you can then
you can cart the the toys around your
house to move the play areas which is
something you want to do you don't want
to have them like spread everywhere a
place looks like a mess other thing
that's great is if you have a toddler
they're going to love to get into this
and it's yeah
oh yeah oh yeah you can also probably
put in here is the the oh man I'm
messing up the names here but it's like
the portable playground the portable
play mat oh yeah is that called activity
man yeah thank you
and I love that we have this for under
100. 30 off and I just love the variety
of colors you could get it in now this
one okay I'm thinking oh rug in a baby's
room absolutely okay I gotta I'm not
gonna lie when I first saw this I
thought 1970s mirrors on the ceilings
everything old is New Again like me but
I love this because it's washable it's
certified vegan and it has a seat it has
a a bottom to it that it's not going to
roll it's not going to roll around the
floor and plus you know if you're
tipping into the room and you don't want
to wake up the baby it's going to muffle
your feet sounds but what's really cool
is is that it is washable and it's not
just for the baby room you could put it
in the living room you want to put one
outside this is flexible but I love that
you could pour white wine on it and it's
fine if the baby has a if the one time
sometimes the babies will take off their
own diapers and leave a little mess
behind no they won't wash them is that
true they will that'll do that that's a
certain age and statement if you're
going to want to get down on the floor
as well Vlad yeah soft you can you can
you can take a little nap on here
yourself and believe it or not you will
you will follow us yeah we have one on
the floor right there that's a six by
six round that's really comfortable to
make it yeah I could see myself yes
you're right Tony I see myself sort of
well I had to take like Burt Reynolds
style price on this game remember Burt
Reynolds 36 oh hey look at you you're
showing you up all right the best move
I've seen all right yes morning deals
all right uh Gail thank you very much
Vlad thank you for that indelible image
we partner with all these companies to
buy anything on your screen uh that you
saw today scan the QR code or head over
to cbsdeals.com to start shopping right
now we will be right back